And there's actually only a single decidable property here.
All of the other properties are undecidable.
Now let's go quickly through them, one by one, to discuss why that is.
So always returns 1; you know that is undecidable by
Rice's Theorem.
It's a similar case here; we already have that.
Adding 2 numbers, Rice's Theorem.
Doesn't do anything, Rice's Theorem.
No matter how you define doesn't do anything;
it will always come back to Rice's Theorem.
Converts an MP3 file, Rice's Theorem.
Reads a file; that is an interesting one,
because you could argue that this does not fall under Rice's Theorem,
but even if you have that argument,
it's still not decidable, because what I could do, for example
so I can modify any program so it will only read a file
once it's done
and that again will allow me to solve the halting problem.
Is the program a virus; Rice's Theorem.
Writes to a file.
similar logic as reads to a file.
Modifies itself; that is an interesting one,
because of course here you could say
Well, of course I could just go through the code
and whenever the program accesses itself,
I know it has that property,
but the thing is this:
the program could have certain lines that suggest this program modifies itself,
but deciding whether those lines will actually be reached
once the program executes,
that again would allow you to solve the halting problem,
so also this isn't decidable.
The same one here; of course you can look at a certain program
and say, Doesn't the program return integers?
but you had a program that can decide
if a program only returns integers,
that again would allow you to solve the halting problem,
And the same thing for downloading data.
If I had a program that designs generally
for any other program if it downloads data,
I could use the same technique as for reading a file.
I could basically modify any program
so that it could run completely on its own data
that it already has included
and downloads data basically to signify that it's done.
If I could decide this in the general case,
then I would have also solved the halting problem.
Now the question of course is,
If this here has any practical relevance;
for example, reading a file,
because for most programs, of course,
you will be able to decide
if they ever read a file or not.
Then again, on the other hand, if you look at general software testing,
this is an interesting question from a perspective of code coverage, for example.
If you could decide if a program reads a file,
and of course you want the program to read a file,
then that would tell you something about the correctness of that program.